Tina I think many people don't really  understand the link between voter  suppression and justice for people like  Brianna Taylor and George Floyd and  Ahmad R Barry can you connect those dots  for us please a lot of my kids that I  mentor have had personal relationships  with violence and so they you know that  response was it doesn't matter if we get  our family to vote it's not going to  make a difference it never has and  they're very hopeless and I think a lot  of black people feel that way and it's  up to us to educate them on the  connection and how I connect the dots  with them is by letting them know that  if you vote you vote for the mayor and  the mayor hires the police chief and the  district attorney and all the people  that are in power to make those changes  in your community and so if you don't  vote then you don't have a voice